시는 진짜 싫어요.
이건 안 돼.
그럼 삼행시는 어때요?
삼행시는 괜찮아요.
아마 안 읽어보셨을 소설일 것 같은데 맞을까요?
아마 안 읽을 것 같은데.
사실 여기에 작가의 의도가 숨겨져 있는 건데
작가의 의도조차...
그럼 더 근본적인 질문을 해봐도 돼요?
네.
허키 님한테 달은 뭐예요?
어?
안녕하십니까.
비주류 초대석 호스트를 맡은 김간지입니다.
누구세요?
아니 여기 김간지까지만 하고
임리다를 하면 안 되지.
그럼 김간지.
김민경.
허키지바새끼입니다.
다 처음부터 또 이죽박죽.
시작부터 시비를 보셨네요.
김민경 님이...
그냥 흘러가는 대로 하면 되는데 왜...
어쨌든 이렇게 저희가 또 모이게 됐는데
이 정도면 저희를 좀 고정이라고 봐도 될까요?
그렇죠.
모르겠어요.
여기 PD님이 항상 웃고 계시잖아요.
네.
그래서 알 수...
속을 알 수가 없죠.
속을 알 수 없는...
속을 진짜 알 수가 없지 않아요?
웃고 계시는데...
네. 어쨌든...
그 사이에 두 분이 저 없이 촬영을 한 번 하셨다고 들었어요.
어떠셨나요? 그 후기 좀 얘기해 주세요.
민경 님이랑 또 촬영을 했죠.
다른 민경 님.
어나더 민경 님.
다른 착하고 밝으신, 해맑으신 민경 님이랑.
뭐야?
눈을 못 보네.
동물을 사랑하시는 민경 님.
수의사 선생님들한테...
조언, 조언 많이 들었어요?
저희가...
내면의 짐승을 어떻게 다뤄야 하는지 계속 다뤘다고 들었어요.
그 민경 님은 그런 말씀은 안 하신다고요.
근데 그러니까 주옥 없이 한 말들이 다 그런 말이었대요.
네, 네. 그렇구나.
제가 볼 때는 한 일주일 정도를 공격할 걸 준비하고 있습니다.
요즘에...
어떻게 하면 공격할 걸...
준비하고 있다고.
어떻게 하면 바꿔 칠까 이러는 거.
네.
아니 근데 제가 듣자 하니까 허키 님이 이런 발언을 하셨다고 해요.
김간지가 토스 먹어야 돼.
사실인가요?
아니 무슨 토스, 삼겹살도 아니고 어떻게 먹습니까, 그걸.
아니 사실이에요?
네, 그런 말을 했는데 어떻게 들으셨죠, 그걸?
무슨 맥락에서 하신 말씀이시죠?
둘이 뭐 하세요?
아니 그래야 이제 좀 콩고물도 받아 먹고, 제가.
제가 이제 이쪽 뉴미디어 쪽 이렇게 하고.
점령하고.
허키가 저기 M 어쩌고 거기 점령해서.
둘이 먹겠다?
근데 말은 그렇게 세게 하는데 꼬박꼬박 대본 다 숙지해 오시고.
시간 맞춰서 항상 20분 빨리 오시잖아요.
네, 너무 빨리 와요.
최소 점수 받으려고 맨날 빨리 오잖아요.
예쁨 받고 싶어서.
어쨌든 저희가 셋이 더 모여주세요 이런 반응들이 있는데
모이고 싶어도 제가 4대 보험 받는 직장인이어서
사실은 뭐 매주 만날 순 없잖아요, 두 분을.
근데 직장보다.
이거 시비 걸 게 있어, 이걸.
아니 직장보다 돈을 더 받으면 되잖아요.
그러니까 이거는.
그렇긴 한데.
이거는.
시청자분들이, 구독자분들이 힘내주셔야 되는 겁니다.
구독자분들이 더 김민경을 애타게 찾으면.
댓글에도 한 10개씩, 3명씩 다 쓰세요, 그냥.
4대 보험을 자기가 뭐?
그냥 뭐 출연료도 내지 마시고.
기부하지 뭐.
그렇게 만들어 주셔야지 매주 볼 수 있다.
그렇죠.
네, 그래서 오늘은 저의 삶이 얼마나 고된지 체험을 한번 시켜드리려고 저의 가장 친한 직장 동료분을 만나봤습니다.
네.
이제 소개를 저희가 해드리겠습니다.
유관 전통이 있죠.
처음 한 30분간은 말을 못하고.
미능사 해외문학팀의 박혜진 편집장님.
환영합니다.
일어나실 것까지야.
오늘 저는 아주 기분이 든든하고 정말 제 여자, 제 오곤을 모셨습니다.
오늘 딱 작정을 하고 오신 것 같아요.
제 여자입니다.
네.
민경.
민경 님이 항상 그렇게 이겨놓고서 또 이겨 먹으려고 자기가 제일
잘하는 책 하자, 자기네 세상.
내가 오늘.
어?
성공을 했는데, 이미.
이미 했는데, 우리가.
저 때니까요.
어.
근데 아주 또 흥미진진합니다.
미능사에서 김민경 님은 어떤 사람일까요?
민경 님은 일처리가 엄청 빠르고.
성격이 급하시죠?
아니요.
네.
저돌적이고
그리고 자기보다 늙은 사람한테 욕하고
유서 부리고
야 내가 이거 다 할 동안 너는 뭐 했냐 니들은
잤냐 뭐
회사 생활 변하지 마
회사 안 다녀봐서
회사가 뭐 그런 양아치 소골인 줄 알아요?
그 또 어떻습니까? 또 설명이
네 죄송해요
빠르고 정확하고 굉장히 유능한 직원이고
여기에서 보여지는 모습보다 조금 더
다정하고 따뜻한 모습인 것 같아요
술집에서
주모 여기 맥주 한 병만
그러면 민경 님이 생각하는 혜진 과장님은?
혜진 님은 사실 지금 일하신 지 10년 차 되셨고
회사에서 유튜브를 2018년부터 하셨어요
사실 유튜브 선배님이신데
유튜버시네요
그 화면 속에서 굉장히 아나운서 같고
진짜 똑 부러진 이미지잖아요
사실 실제로는
굉장히 엉뚱함
그 내면을 잘 보여주진 않지만
한 번 보여주면 끝도 없이
굉장히 엉뚱하다
돌리는 거 아니야 이거?
그냥 마음에 안 든다는 소리를 길게 하시는 거지
유능하지 못한 선배님이시다라는
엉뚱하시다
아 미치겠다
좀 이따가 회사도 안 다녀봤으면서
회사 다니면 되죠
어디 어디 어디에 갈 건데 어디
어디가 어딘가는 받아주겠죠
그러면 이어지는 질문으로
혜진 님 오늘 두 분 실제로 만나보니까
첫인상이 어떠세요?
한 분씩 차를차를 말씀해 주세요
근데 진짜 제일 처음 든 생각은
목소리가 너무 좋으신 것 같아요
그 말의 내용은 어떨지 몰라도
일단 목소리가 좋으니까
좋게 들리는
전쟁을 시작하잖아요
선전포고를 하자마자
그런 효과가 있는 거 같아요
오케이 목소리가 좋다
그럼 허키 님 첫인상 어떠세요?
자본이 내 느낌
더러운 자본이 느껴진다
트롤레터리의 보혈을 빨아먹는
흑막이 느껴진다
부티 난다
네 맞아요
그리고요?
토스랑 잘 어울리시는 것 같아요
제작진분들이 엄청 크게 웃으셨어요
그 대목에서
굉장히 비웃으셨는데
그래서 오늘 저희 주제가 책이지 않습니까
그래서 저와 혜진 님이 어떤 홈그라운드
주전공이라고 할 수 있는데
고민이 되는 부분은
두 분은 책을 언제 마지막으로 혹시 읽으셨나요?
기억이 안 납니다
저도 기억이 안 나요
근데 저는 확실히 활자 중독자긴 해요
무슨 소리야
왜요?
뭔가 계속 읽고 있어요
근데 그거는 살려면 해야 되는 얘기잖아요
그래도 기억을 더듬어 보자면
언제가 굳이 마지막이세요?
굳이 말을 하려고 해도 도저히 기억이 안 나요
아 진짜?
정의란 무엇인가 책을 샀어요
거짓말하지 마
가끔 그럴 때 있잖아요
아 돈 좀 뿌리고 싶다
아 그냥 땅에 돈 좀 버리고 싶네
그냥 허당에 들어가서
정의란 무엇인가를 샀다가
근데 저도 마찬가지인데
아니 잠깐만
그냥 일단 책을 사요
사긴 사세요?
사긴 사요
그 사는 것만 해요
허세? 디스플레이?
허세라니요?
누구 보여주겠다고 그걸 허세해요
그냥 집에다가 내가 그걸 갖고 있다라는
그거 찍어서 인스타에 올리시잖아요
안 올리죠
아니 더 지독한 사람들은 그냥 아무데나 한 장 딱 핀 다음에
거기에 문구를 찍어 올리는 겁니다
아니요 그분들 다 실제로 읽으신 거예요 거기까지
찔리나 보네
그래서 오늘은 저 혼자 두 분을 상담하기가 좀 너무 벅찰 것 같아서
두 불량배 분들의 교양을 채워줄 공부방 방문교사로 혜진 님을 초빙했어요
초빙했어요?
저는 방문교사 좋아합니다
왜 좋아하세요?
방문교사님 저희의 교양과 독서를 책임져 주신
아니 그럴 자격이 있는 게
중학교 때 도서부를 하셨다고요
그때 얘기 좀 해주세요
중학교 때 저희 때만 해도 약간 이런 클럽 활동?
이런 거를 되게 장려하는 분위기여 가지고
하나씩 다 했어야 됐는데
저는 그때 자부심 있는 되게 일명 책벌레였기 때문에
그때는 이렇게 손을 들어서 도서부를 했던 경험이 있고
되게 재밌었어요
저는 당구부
당구부라는 게 있을 수 있나?
당구부가 있었고
아니 본인이 만든 부대요?
아니 진짜 있었어요
포켓볼 이런 거 있었던 거 같아요
포켓볼부랑 영화감성부
근데 그 두 개가 아마 유일하게 학교 밖으로 나가는 클럽 활동이었어요
학교 밖으로 나갈 수 있는 게 좋은 거니까
알겠습니다
그럼 허키 님 어떤 활동 하셨어요? 중학교 때
어? 잘...
네
저는...
안 했어?
아니 있었는데
아니 내가 이거 밝히기 싫은데
아니요 밝혀주세요
종이적 기호 같은 거 아니에요?
저... 저 그거였습니다
뜨개질 뭐
저 힙합 동아리였습니다
심지어는 제가 만들었어요 그냥
그때 그럼 랩퍼였어요?
랩 했지?
랩퍼였죠 랩퍼였죠
오 한 소절 해주시겠지
저희 동네에서 중학교 때 힙합은
만화부랑 비슷한...
거의 그 수준...
그런 느낌
그중에 진지했던 사람은 저 밖에 없었어요
오...
그러면 학창 시절 한 번도 책에 빠져들었던 기억이 없으신가요?
좀 그때 좋아했던 책 같은 게 있으면 말씀해주시면 좋을 것 같아요
저는 의외로 책을 어릴 때는 좀 많이 읽었습니다
나의 라임 오렌지 나무
오오오오오오오오오오오오오오오오오오오오오오
아큐 정전
오오오오오오오오오오오오오오오오오오오오어
아큐 정전?
네
짜라두스트라는 이렇게 말했다
오
세 페이지에 읽고
판치기로?
그 책 괜찮았어요
근데 간지 님 각 잡고 공부를 하셨으면 되게 잘 하셨을 거 같아요
되게 영특하시잖아요
저는 근데 수학을 진짜 못해요
뺄셈을 아직도 손가락으로 하거든요
아 진짜요?
집에서 여기까지 어떻게 온 거예요?
그건 수학이 필요 없어요
수학이랑 상관없잖아요
그건 공감, 각정, 감각만 있으면 돼요
근데 저는 그것도 약해가지고
화장실 갔다 와서 어디로 가는지
그건 저도 그래요
항상 헷갈려요
아 근데 길을 못 찾는 이런 특징이
저 좀 심각하거든요 근데 이거
이게 그 파트너에게 충실해서 일부 종사하는 남편의 특징일 수 있대요
이거 제가 어느 다큐에서 본 건데
무슨 소리야 뭐라고?
다큐 맞아요?
네 어느 다큐에서 본 거예요 진짜요
EBS였던 것 같아요
길을 못 찾으면 1등 신랑 갑니다
릴스 아니야 릴스?
아니야 아니야
왜냐면은 제가 이걸 선명하게 기억하는 이유가 있는데
쥐 있잖아요 쥐
쥐로 실험을 한 거예요
근데 길을 잘 찾는 쥐는
낮에 다니다가 어떤 예쁜 암컷을 봤어
그럼 자기 와이프 쥐가 잠들었을 때
밤에 거기를 슉 찾아가는 거예요
그래서 딴짓을 하고
슉 돌아와서 자는 척을 하는 거예요
아니 발상 자체가 너무 남성혐오적이에요
아니 아니 아니 아니
아니 이건 과학이에요
아니 이거 이미
나 쥐잖아 이거
그렇게 하면 얘기가
EBS래요 EBS
EBS
근데 길을 못 찾는 쥐는
나갈 생각을 못 하는 거예요
왜냐면 나갔다가 길을 잃으면
돌아올 수조차 없기 때문에
아 바보 온달 스타일이다
그래서 그 집을 떠나지 않고 잔다는 거예요
근데 제가 왜 이거를 잘 기억을 하냐면
이거는 틀림없는 사실인 게
제 기억 조작이 아니라 사실인 게
제가 저의 그 파트너가 너무 길을 못 찾아서
머리 끝까지 화가 난 적이 한두 번이 아니었어요
근데 이 다큐를 보고
마음이 녹아내리면서 용서를 용서를 하고
이해를 하게 됐거든요
그래서 저는 이게 되게 긍정적인 특징이다
더 진화한 남자라면
파트너만 있을 때 길을 못 찾고
그냥 잘 찾는 사람일 수도 있지 않을까요
아 길 되게 잘 찾으시나 봐요
저요?
아 저는 아예
길치에요 길치
저 아직도 왼쪽 오른쪽 구분을 못해요
네 혜진님 여기까지 대화를 좀 해보니까
두 분 성향을 좀 파악하셨는지 어떤 생각이 드세요?
간지님은 생각보다 감수성이 예민한
사춘기를 보냈던 소년이 아니었을까라는 생각이 드는 게
교과서에 나온 어떤 작품을 기억하고 있다라는 거는
꽤 모범생이었다라고 저는 생각을 하거든요
시간이 지나면은 다 까먹는데
어쩌면 도서부에 가고 싶지만
마지막까지 손을 안 들었다가
강제로 끌려가는 그림으로
도서부에 갔을 수도 있을 것 같은
그런 느낌이셨다
인정하십니까?
들켰죠
아니요 하나도
그럼 허키님은 어떤 인상을 받으셨나요?
별로 안 듣고 싶은데요
결론을 도출하려면
데이터가 있어야 되는데
그쵸 뭐 말한 게 없는데
아직은 미스테리다 알겠습니다
그래서 이것만으로 아직 파악이 어려우신 것 같아서
두 분한테 인생 책 리스트를 받아 봤어요
먼저 허키님 리스트부터 보겠습니다
이상하다 그럼 내가 봐봐
어떻게 된 거죠 이게 뭐
고등학생인가요?
뭐라도 적으라고 하시길래
본인이 산 책이 있으세요?
다 수업 시간에 읽으라고 한 책이 아닌가 하는
아니에요 이거 다 제가
제 선택으로 골라서 샀습니다
스티븐 킹을 읽으라고 하는 학교 수업이 있나요?
스티븐 킹은 그냥 제가
소설에 관심이 있었던 적이 있어요 그냥
왠지 몰라요
스티븐 킹
그냥 관심 있어서 사서 읽었는데 재밌었어요
아 어쩌면
데이터를 너무 안 주신 이유는
마음속에 책을 진짜 좋아하는 마음이 있어서
그럴지도 모르겠어요
너무 큰 비밀이 있는 사람은 쉽게 말을 못하잖아요
그런 거 아닐까요?
여기서 힌트를 발견하셨군요
저는 근데 저런 사람 좀 좋아해요 저렇게 그냥
툭툭 빨빠빨 써가지고 빨리 내고 이런 다작한
그리고 알기 쉬운 경음악 편곡법 저는
사실 처음 들어보면
제가 처음 들었던 책인데 어떤 책인지 좀 소개를 해 주시죠
저거는 꼭 음악한다고 하는 애들 집에 가면 있는 책이거든요
그래서 제가 궁금해서 한번 봤는데
교본이거든요 그냥
그런데도 저 안에 이상한 캐릭터들이 있어요
선생님이 한 명 있고 제자 두 명 이러면서
참 쉽죠? 이러면서 대사가 있어요
일러스트가 있어요?
일러스트는 없고 대본이 있어요
선생님 땡땡 이렇게
선생님 땡땡
여기서 어떻게 해야지 뭐...
그게 있을까요? 이러면 학생들이 막 의견을 내요
그런 어떤 내용들이 좀 웃겼다
귀여워서
네 인상 깊은 게 무라카미류의 스트레인지 데이즈인데요
이 책은 왜 인생 책이죠?
저는 진짜 랜덤하게 넣은 건데
무라카미류 소설을 제가 어렸을 때 좀 많이 보긴 했어요
지금 제가 다시 몇 장 이렇게 펼쳐 보면은 또
이걸 왜 좋아했나 싶은 생각도 들기도 하고
어렸을 땐 좀 좋았던 거 같아요
근데 이게 약간 좋아하는 책의 특징인 거 같아요
너무 한 시절에 나를 딱 사로잡아본...
딱 시간이 지난 후에 다시 그 책을 봤을 때 내가 이걸 왜 좋아했지?
그러니까 지금 보라 그러면 안 봤을 거예요.
근데 그때는 조금 그 감성이 좀 맞았다.
그럼 혜진 님, 여기까지 리스트를 보고는 어떤 사람 같은지 한번 평을 해 주실까요?
이 학생, 어떤 학생인지.
왜 이렇게 자꾸 분석으로 가시죠?
대본에 나와 있어요.
왜 저를 자꾸 파악하려고 이렇게.
여기 선생님으로 오셨기 때문에 저희가 오늘 세 명의 학생입니다.
아니다. 정정할게요.
두 분을 가르치기 위해 선생님이 오셨고 제가 오늘 호랑이 교관 역할을 맡습니다.
갑자기.
그냥 호랑이 아니에요? 호랑이?
어?
그냥 호랑이 아니에요?
네. 어떤 학생 같나요? 허키 님.
어, 근데 뭐 해외 소설 그리고 이제 국내 소설 그리고 실용서 그리고 이제 글쓰기 작법서 이런 것들을 되게 골고루 좋아하시는 걸로 봐서 아닌 척하시지만 되게 숨겨놓은 교양이 많으신 분이 아닌가라고 생각이 들었고.
왜 아닌 척하시나요?
네.
왜 아닌 척을 할까요?
그러니까 자꾸 뭔가 보여주지 않으시려고 하는데 사실은 보여주고 싶은 건가? 왜 책을 이렇게 올렸지?
이렇게 그 사람이 복잡해요.
이렇게 쉽지 않더라고요.
그러니까 아무도 나한테 다가오지 마.
난 사실 근데 관종이야.
내 취향을 알아줘.
근데 아무도 나한테 토 달지 마.
이걸 동시에 하고 있는 사람이라는 거죠?
네. 맞아요.
모순된 인간이다.
인정합니다.
네.
그러면 혜진 님이 이런 사람에게 세계문화가 있다면 어떻게 생각하시나요?
그리고 저는 둘 중에 하나 더 먹어봤는데요.
네.
뭐...
그래요?
그럼 제가 online 조금 informational load confer 를 들여 드릴게요.
있어요?
추천하는 이유가 있다면 뭘까요?
그 과거에 좋아했던 책들이 약간 좀 힘을 딱 주고 있는 약간 이런 센 책들을 좋아하셨던 것 같은데 특히 무라카미류 같은 작가들을 보면
근데 이건 반대로 힘을 확 뺀 작품이에요. 이 작가가 버지니아 울프의 여자친구거든요.
우정 그 이상을 나눠 썼던 관계였는데 주인공이 88세 할머니인 소설을 쓴 거예요. 88세 할머니가 원래는 정치인의 아내로
한 사람의 인생으로 보면 굉장히 성공적이고 영화로운 삶을 산 거죠. 그리고 남편을 내조하는 역할도 충실히 했던 어떤 여성인데
남편이 죽고 나니까 이제 자식들끼리 모여서 얘기를 하는 거예요. 우리 엄마 어떻게 모실까?
이거 한 사람이 모시기는 좀 부담스러우니까 엄마가 우리 들지
집을 돌아다니면서 사시는 걸로 하자. 막 이렇게 회의를 하고 있는데 이제 엄마가 얘기를 하는 거죠.
아니 나는 누구 집에도 가지 않아. 나는 30년 전에 내가 이미 혼자 살고 싶은 집을 봐준 적이 있어.
그 집에 들어가 살겠다 라고 이야기를 하면서 엄마가 그 집에 들어가서 혼자의 삶을 사는데 정말 88년 동안 내가
별어봤던 삶을 살겠어 라고 생각을 하는 거예요. 그게 뭐였냐면 나만 생각하는 삶이에요.
음.
막
이 사람을 막 여러 명이 찾아와요. 자식들도 찾아오고 친구들도 찾아오고 옛날에 첫사랑도 찾아오고 하는데
딱 첫사랑이 찾아온 순간 아직 저는 젊은 독사니까 그런 기대를 하게 되는 거예요. 아 근데 로맨스가 펼쳐지려나?
근데 이 첫사랑과의 관계도 딱 거기에 머물러요. 이렇게 나란히 앉아서 같이 책을 보면서 그 시린 무릎을 난로에 녹이는 그런 장면이 있는데
딱 그런 우정으로 딱 단정하게 정리를 하고 오로지 자기 자신에게 집중하고
하는 노년으로의 딱 그렇게 조용하게 가는 삶을 그린 작품인데 나이 듦에 대한 책이기도 하고 아까 막 무라카미류를 좋아한다고 말씀하셨던 시절이 있으니까 무라카미류가 되게 약간 하루키랑 좀 대비되는 작가잖아요.
아 그래요?
투 무라카미. 무라카미 하루키, 무라카미류.
이름이 비슷해서 그런 건가?
무라카미 하루키가 되게 약간 사색적이고 감성적인 글을 쓴다면 무라카미류는 약간 폭주하는 청춘의 이미지?
네. 무라카미류가 되게 약간 사색적이고 감성적인 글을 쓴다면 무라카미류는 약간 폭주하는 청춘의 이미지?
네. 그래서 이 시기를 떠나와서 내가 이때 읽었던 작품 못 읽겠는데 약간 오그라드는데라고 생각을 하신다면 지금
정확히 그렇습니다.
이런 작품을 한 번 읽어보시면 나 생각보다 이런 여성 작가의 할머니에게 잘 맞네 라고 하실 수도 있지 않을까.
맞아요. 눈물 흘리실 것 같아요.
100% 굉장히 진단을 잘하셨네요. 정확히 저를 파악하셨네요. 대단하신데요? 아니 어떻게 알았지.
그렇습니다.
감사합니다.
허세 그만 부리고 그만 복잡하게 살고
마음을 열고 이제 대화를 한번 해보도록
편하게 살아라 이런 메시지가 있는 것 같아요
알겠습니다
그 다음 간지님 리스트를 한번 보겠습니다
우선은 리스트가 짧으세요
이거야말로 딱 고등학교 나오는
미국 고등학생 책 그 리스트 같은데
그래요?
그러니까 제가 뭐 책에 그렇게 조회가 깊지가 않기 때문에
두 책 다 공통점이 있거든요
그런 것 같아요
욕이 좀 나와요
저는 그게 좋더라고요
그래서 욕두 문자가 좀 나와줘야지
제가 브람스를 좋아하십니까? 읽다가 진짜 속이 터져가지고
브람스를 좋아하십니까?
이게 무슨
이게 책이야?
둘 다 좀 반항적이네요
맞아요
스무 살 이후에 읽었어요?
네
오 그럼 말이 달라지는데
그러니까 어릴 때
왜요 어렸을 때 읽었어야 정상인가요?
아니요 아니요 들어볼게요
라임 오렌지나 어린 왕자 같은 건 어릴 때 읽은 거고
계속 저도 문화적 허세와 저의 어떤 문화적인 욕망들을 계속 탐구를 했었죠
책도 그 중에 하나였는데 재미가 없는 거예요
근데 그 중에서 친구가 찰스 부코스키를 추천을 해줬는데
확실히 다른 책이랑 좀 다르다고 느낀 게
이거를 무슨 좀 나쁘게 말하면 인터넷 올라온 글 같은 느낌도 있어요
근데 저는 아 나 오늘 시를 써야겠어 이래가지고
화려한 미사억으로 치장된 그런 예술보다
저런 게 진짜 예술처럼 느껴질 때가 있잖아요
그냥 오늘 보드카 사서 마시고 그 새끼한테 꺼지라고 얘기했다
뭐 이런 문장들 자체가
와 죽이네 멋있다
그래서 어 이게 책이란 게 꼭 다 그렇진 않구나
뭐 무라카미 류은지 뭐 무진 기행 뭐 이렇게
약간 엘리트 같은 느낌?
네 그렇죠 거기에 저항하려는
심지어 또 이제 하측민의 입장에서 좀 대회에 쓴 것들이 있으니까
그래서 좋았다
저 주변에도 이제 부코스키 좋다고 그러는 사람들이 몇 명 있거든요
괜찮죠 그 사람들이
공통점이 있거든요
근데 뭐죠?
아주 고집이 너무 세고 비관적이고
아
약간 우울하고
그게 부코스키 잘못 먹어서 그런 거예요
이걸 제대로 잘 먹으면 거기서 아 나는 이제 이것을 이렇게 난 다르게 가야지 라고 해야 되는데
근데 제가 알기로는 혜진님이 부코스키를 좋아하시잖아요
네 맞아요
근데 결이 다른데
아니 근데 좀 비슷하다니까요
비슷해요?
도서부야? 도서부야?
원래 제가 혜진님 자리에 있었어야 돼요
혜진님이 여기 있었어야 되고
아 근데 저는
그 빌어먹을 아비투스 때문에
제가 운 나쁘게 여기로 온 것 뿐입니다 네
조금 더 얘기를 해주시자면 부코스키 어떤 작가인지
부코스키 하면 말씀하신 것처럼 되게 뭔가 엘리트주의 작가들의 반대편에 있는 작가고
이 우체국이라는 그 소설처럼 실제로 12년 정도 우체부로 일했었어요
그리고 아 내가 이 우체국에서 살다가 미칠 것이냐 아니면 우체국 밖으로 나가서 굶을 것이냐
이 선택의 기로에서 나는 우체국 밖으로 나가서 글을 쓰는 대신 굶겠다 라고 선택을 해서 나왔던 작가고
그렇기 때문에 그런 발언에서도 되게 자유로워서
뭐 누가 셰익스피어에 관해서 추천을 했대나
그랬더니 난 셰익스피어 안 좋아해 난 톨스토이도 싫어해 이렇게 말할 정도로
그냥 완전 탈권위주의적인
참 고집스럽네요 사람이
그 정도 고집이 있어야 된다 책을 쓰려면은 그 정도 고집이 있어야지
근데 저는 그 찰스 부코스키를 모르는데 딱시 한 편을 알아요
기억하실지 모르겠지만
회사에서
되게 지루하게 일하고 있는데 좀 힘든 날이었는데 혜진님이 채팅으로 이 시를 한번 읽어보세요 링크를 보내줬어요
그게 찰스 부코스키 두 알자였는데 그거를 읽고 아 그냥 무슨 말을 나한테 해주고 싶었는지 너무 알겠는 거예요
잠시 질문
네
그렇게 그 일하는 시간에
아니 아니 진짜 궁금해서 그래요
아니
그냥 이 시 한번 읽어보렴 이러면서
네
이게 흔한 일인가요
아니 근데 그게
디스 신청하는 거죠 이렇게
그럼 저는 부코스키처럼 꺼져 바쁘니까 꺼지라고 라고 얘기할 것 같아요
그 여기에 있어요 망할 놈의 예술을 한답시고라는 이 시집에 있는데
엄청 좋아하실 것 같아요
진짜 좋아하실 것 같아요 저는 오늘 다시 읽은
왜 나까지 포함시켜
아니 왜냐면
엄청 좋아하실 것 같아요
제가 다시 오늘 읽으면서 두 알자를 읽으면서 간지허키가 생각났어요
오 맞다
두 알자
진짜
왈자로 뭐야
진짜로
좀만 읽어주시면 안 돼요
왈자
네
몇 페이지지
진짜 시를
진짜 읽는다고
앞에서 시를 낭독하는 게 싫으세요
시 낭독을 하시겠다고요
시를 소리내세요 읽는다고
근데 편집부에서는 늘상 읽는 일이에요
오 이거 되게 쇼킹하네요
진짜 쇼킹한데
길어서 조금만 읽어드릴게요
너무 생경한데요
꼬붕들이 죄다 지켜보는 가운데 제드가 내게 술병을 건네고 내가 3분의 1을 마셔버린 그 순간에
망할 그때는 우리 둘한테 실패란 없을 줄 알았는데 그게 아니더란 말이지
나는 삼사십 년 만에 겨우 몇 걸음 전진했을 뿐이다
그런데 제드 오늘 밤 아직 여기 있나 모르겠지만 그때 깜빡하고 못 한 말이 있어
그 술 고마웠어
그 술 고맙고
저는...
뭐가 지나간 건지 모르겠어요
저는 시를 싫어합니다
시를 진짜로 싫어해요
왜 싫어하세요?
왜 싫어하세요? 시를?
싫어할 건 또 뭐예요?
시는 진짜 싫어요
이건 안 돼
다 좋아할 수 있어
다 참을 수 있어
시는 안 돼
그럼 삼행시는 어때요?
삼행시는 괜찮습니다
삼행시는...
좋아요
근데 이게 약간 감성이 다를 수밖에 없는 게
왜냐면 두 R자는
학창 시절에 얘는 운동부 누구고
나는 작가
얘는 우리 학교에서 운동 제일 잘하는 애
얘는 우리 학교에서 글 제일 잘 쓰는 애
이렇게 둘이
누가 생각해도 뭔가 될 줄 알았던 둘인 거야
근데 이 둘이 서로 분야는 달라도
서로 인정하면서
그리고 서로 좀 으스대면서 인정해 주면서
이렇게 다녔는데
시간이 지나고 보니까
우리 학교에서 일을 안 되고
나도 별거 없었더라
근데 그때 네가 나한테 그렇게 술을 건네고
다른 애들이 우리를 선망의 눈으로 바라보던
그 순간의 짜릿함이
나는 아직 마음에 남아있어
그 술 고마웠어
라는 얘기거든요
그러니까 이게 우리는
어쨌든 지금 회사원으로 살고 있으니까
이게 와서 훅 때려
근데 이분들은 여전히
왈자로 살고 계시니까
뭐냐면은
하고 싶은 걸 하면 살고 있으니까
근데
와서 때리진 않는 거
제가 하고 싶은 게
회사원일 수도 있잖아요
저한테 꿈이 있을지 모르게
저의 꿈은 윈윈사 팀장일 수도 있는 건데
완전 긁혔어
제대로 긁었어
그래서 그게 특별히
이렇게 안 오는 거 같아요
아니 근데 완전
한 소리를 들으니까 이해가 되긴 합니다
어쨌든 그렇습니다
그리고 호밀밭의 파수꾼은
대중픽인 거 같은데
사실 저거는 고등학생 때 읽었어야 되는 건데
어떤 점을 좋아하시는 거예요?
존 레논과
대통령 암살범들이 다 좋아했던 책이라는
얘기를 듣고
그 음모론 아세요?
호밀밭의 파수꾼
암살범들이 왜 이렇게 좋았냐면은
주인공을 비롯한
주변 인물들에게
셀린저가
미리 지정을 내려놓은 거예요
암호로 말이죠
그걸 딱 읽는 순간 자기도 모르게
어? 존 레논을 암살해야겠다는
생각이 들게끔 만든
책이라는 음모론이 있습니다
서프라이즈 같은 데서
진짜 서프라이즈인데
근데 왜 읽으셨냐고요 어떻게 막을 수 있어요
나에게 지령이 내려진 것 같은데
나는 누구를 쏘면 되는지
나는 누군지
나한테 내려진 지령이 뭔지
누구를 증인하는 걸까?
뭡니까 선생님?
못 느꼈어요
선택받은 자가 아니었네요
근데 저는 이 리스트를 봤을 때
어떤 사람인 것 같냐면
한숨부터 시작했죠 지금
아
이미 40이 넘었어요
뭐야 그건 봐도 알 수 있어요
아니 들어보세요
끝까지 들어보세요
이제 시작이에요 이제 시작
안경을 썼고요
아니 아니 아니 그게 아니고
이미 40이 넘었어요 나는
근데 내면에
어린 소년이 있고
반항적인
나 소년이 있어
근데 난 40이 넘었어
아 난 이 사실이 싫지만은 않아
하지만 당당하게 밝힐 일은 아니야
하지만 나는 이 소년을 긍정하고 싶어
하면서 소년을 끌어안고 있는
어떤 40대가 보이거든요
소설을 잘 쓰시네요
저는 약간 공감합니다
그렇죠
재밌네요
무슨 저기 무당치 본 거 같네요
신점 보는 거
되게 잘 맞네요
어떤 생각하세요
저도 되게 비슷하게 느꼈고
저 셀린저의 홀든 콜필들도
사실 민경님이 말한 거랑 비슷한
맞아요
성격의 사람이거든요
가식도 싫어하고
계속 여기서 3번인가 4번인가 자퇴하는 이유가
그 사립학교에서
그 교장 교감 학부모가
맨날 모여서 하는
그런 의미 없는 말들
가식적인 말들
서로 이제 뭐 뒷돈 주고
뒷돈 주는 애를 더 잘 봐주고 하는
이런 관계에 정말 나는 염증 난다
라고 해서 계속 학교를 나오고 나오고 하는 건데
근데 얘가 마지막에
자기 여동생한테
오빠 진짜 떠난다 라는 말을 하려고
그 여동생이 학교를 찾아가요
근데 학교 담벼락에
막
욕이 막 써있는 거예요
F로 시작하는 욕들이 막 써있는 거예요
근데 아직 어린데 여동생이 보기에
이 욕은 너무 심한 욕이라고 생각해서
그 와중에 그걸 지워요
근데 저는 그 장면을 되게 좋아하거든요
순수하다 라는
생각도 들고
어떤 면에서
그 순수함을 지킬 수 있는 거는
결국 때가 탄 자잖아요
나는 때 탔다
그렇기 때문에 누군가를 지킬 수 있는
힘이 있다 라는 거를 느끼는 순간에
이 홀든 쿨필드가 딱
소년에서 어른으로 넘어간다고 생각하는데
뭔가 그
그런 느낌을 갖고 계신
소년이면서 어른이면서
수염난 피터팬이다
고슴도치 같은 소년
속은 여리지만 이렇게 까시를
그게 제가 사실은
이 책이
개정판이 나왔는데
그걸 제가 편집을 했거든요
그래서
그 띠지에 넣은 문장이 있는데
그게 간지님을 잘 표현해주는
말인 것 같아요 마지막 문장인데
또 읽으시는 거죠?
아니 읽으세요
주인은 양도기신가 봐요
고고
아무한테도
아무 이야기도 절대 하지 마라
하게 되면 모두 보고 싶어진다
이게 간지님 같아요
알겠습니다
그러면
혜진님이 이런 분에게
수염난 피터팬에게
세계문화 전집 책을 하나 추천한다면 어떤 책이 있을까요?
저는 근데
아까 허키님은
뭔가 이제까지 안 읽어보신
책을 소개해드렸다면
사실 간지님은
계속 이런
약간 이런 뭔가
이런 보법으로 계속
가시는 게
반항으로 계속 가야 되는데
뭔가 매력이라는 생각이 들어요
왜냐면
그런 말이 있어요
너 그게 어울려
너 계속 그렇게
거탈번위로 살아
출판사 이게 패심이야
웃는 얼굴로
좋은 뜻으로 한 말이에요
웃으면 조롱하게
좋은 뜻으로 한 말인데 그게 왜냐면
홀든 콜필드
호밀바테 파수꾼이 처음에
출간을 하려고 막 했을 때 연재도 하려고
했었는데 신문사에서 다 거절을
당했었어요 근데 그 이유가 뭐냐면
아 그러니까 청소년계 반항
알겠는데
이 홀든 콜필드의
자기 독백이 너무 시끄럽고
듣기 싫으니까
이 소설 누가 보겠어 라는 의견이 되게
많았던 거예요 왜냐면
이 소설을 읽은 사람들은 다 최소한
중장년이었을 테니까
그 당시에 이제 좋은
소설이라고 평가받는 소설은
그 서사가 있는 소설이었던
반면 이 작품은
그 화자의 목소리
주인공의 목소리가 너무 크게 들리는
소설이었던 거죠 근데
그 목소리 때문에
사실 홀든 콜필드의 목소리가
듣기 싫어지면 나이가
든 것이다 라는 말이 있어요
근데 여전히 이 작품을
좋아하시고 어 나는 그렇게
자기 독백적이고
자의식 과잉의 뭔가
그런 문장들이 난
여전히 좋고 재밌어
라고 생각하시는 거잖아요
아니 모르죠
그게 나쁜 뜻을 하는 거 아니에요
얼마 전에는 안 읽어봤으니까
넌 그런 놈이잖아요
너 아직 그런 놈이잖아
마음 둘먹고도 아직도 자의식 과잉이지
너 아니 근데 그게
나쁜 뜻을 한 말 진짜 아니에요
거의 심리 상담 받으러 온 것 같죠
갈비뼈 벗겨지는 느낌 아니에요 혹시?
그래서 추천하시는 책이
그래서 추천하는 책이
토마스만이라는 독일 작가의
토니오 크래거
혹시 읽어보셨나요?
표시가 굉장히 예쁘고
잠깐 만져봐도 될까요?
이게 딱
2호선에서 먹히는
재질이거든요
토마스랭이요?
토마스만
토마스만이라는 작가의
토니오 크래거라는 작품이고
토마스만이라는 작가가
이런 걸 갈등했던 작가에요
나는 시민이냐 예술가냐
불량배냐
선생이냐 이런 것들 계속 갈등하던
그 자장에서
글을 썼던 작가이고
이 토니오 크래거 역시
그런 갈등이 있는 주인공이
자기만의 삶을 찾아가는 내용이거든요
근데 제가 아까
보법이라고 말씀드린 이유가
사실 이 소설에서 제가 제일
좋아하는 대목이
그 토니오 크래거가
자기만의 길을 갈 때의
걸음걸이를 묘사한 대목이에요
근데 제가 이 부분을 한번
읽어드려도 될까요?
그는 약간 태만하고도
어슬렁거리는 태도로
혼자 휘파람을 불며
고개를 삐뚜루미하고서
먼 산을 바라보면서
자기가 가지 않으면
안 될 길을 갔다
나랑 전혀 다른데?
그런데도
만약 그가 길을 잘못 갔다면
그것은 몇몇 사람에게는
바른 길이라는 것이
애당초 없기 때문이었다
라는 대목인데
그냥 물론 이게 저희가
직장인으로서 아티스트를 볼 때
갖는 어떤
선입견? 일 수도 있겠지만
저희 눈에는 이렇게
뭔가 고개를 삐뚜루미하고
내가 낸데 하면서
길을 가시는 모습이 멋있어
보여서 계속 그
보법을 유지하시라고
저는 그 김간지의 모습을
완전히 딱 그냥
다 소개를 한 느낌이었어요
이것이 당신의 모습입니다
당신이 가고자 하는
삐딱하게 하고 먼 곳을 바라보면서
그리고 가보자
이런 느낌?
저는 허리 때문에 최대한 곧게
걸으려고 노력을 해요
디스크가 심해지면 안 되니까
너무 정확히
보신 것 같아요
그래서 이 작품을 꼭 추천드립니다
고맙습니다
나중에 저희가 음악 추천해 주는
시간도 있었으면 좋겠네요
근데 힙합 엄청 좋아하세요
왜 힙합일 거라고 생각하시죠?
아 왜냐면
힙합을 되게 좋아하세요
그래서 빈지노 보려고 창원까지
내려가서
그건 힙합을 좋아하는 게 아니라
빈지노를 좋아하는 게 아니라
이렇게 두 분의 독서력을 검증해 보고
어떤 인간인지
진단도 해봤는데요
두 분이 중학교 때 못했던
도서부 활동을
60년 만에 체험시켜드리려고
준비를 했어요
이름하여 어둠의 독서클럽을
저희가 준비했지 않았겠습니까?
어둠의 독서클럽
그래서 녹화하기 전에 제작진분들이
집으로 책을 보내주셨다고 들었어요
다 읽어오셨나요?
다 읽었습니다
오 봐봐
참실한 분이라니까
사실은 책 좋아하지
한 장씩 먹었어요
네 그러면 첫 번째 책은
어떤 책인지 소개를 해주실 텐데요
바로
달과 육펜스입니다
썸어신봄에
내용을 혜진님이 한번 간단히 정리를 해주실까요?
이 책입니다
야 드디어 달과 육펜스다
이거 봐봐
이런 책이 나올 때 박수 치는지 안 치는지도
모르는 거야
독서 모임을 해본 적이 없었거든요
뭐 룰이 있어요?
누가 박수를 쳐요 여기서
그럼 이런 거 아니에요? 내가 딱 하고 있으면
이번엔 너로 정했다 달과 육펜스
그럼 나는
무진기에
여기서 얘네가 싸워가지고
여기서 박수도 안 치면
무슨 교양 없는 사람처럼
간지가 달과 육펜스를 꺼냈어
줄거리 한번 소개를 해주시죠
네 제가 영화
월드컵에서 허키님이
예술가가 나오는 영화 안 좋아한다
예술가의 고뇌를 담은 걸
안 좋아한다 라고
말씀하신 걸 들었는데
이건 아마 좋아하실 거예요
왜냐면 거장이 썼으니까
예술가가 나오는 소설 중에서
가장 재밌는 소설이 아닌가
저는 그렇게 생각을 하는데
주인공이 처음부터 예술가였던 건 아니에요
주인공은 처음엔 증권 중개인이었어요
예를 들면 토스 직원들처럼
돈을 다루는 일을 했던 거죠
그러던 어느 날 나이도 마흔이 넘어서
이 사람이 돌연 처자식도 버리고
그리고 직업도 버리고
파리로 가게 됩니다
사람들이 이제 웅성웅성 그렇겠죠
무슨 사고를 친 거야 아니면 여자가 생긴 거야
근데 알고 보니까
이 사람은 그림을 그리고자 하는
욕망 때문에
이 모든 것들을 버리고 파리로 간 거였어요
원래 어디 있었는데요?
영국 런던에 있었는데
런던에 증권 중개인이었는데
안 읽으셨어요?
네?
저는 그냥
내 것만 읽으라 그래가지고
정말 불량하네요
근데 이걸 믿지 못한 와이프가
한번 점검하러 가야 될 거 아니에요
진짜 여자가 없는지
점검하러 파리로 갑니다
그랬더니 정말 굉장히 불편한 의자에서
아무것도 없는 호텔방에서
혼자 그림을 그리고 있는 거예요
이 사람은 정말로
그림을 그리고 싶은 욕망 하나 때문에
모든 것들을 버리고 온 셈인데
이때부터 타인의 시선이라던가
자기가 기존에 갖고 있었던
도덕관념 이런 것 따위는
안중에도 없고
지독한 예술적인 이기주의
이것만 가지고 있는 인물로
완전히 변모를 합니다
결국 이 사람은 나중에 나이가 들어서
타이티 섬에서
나병에 걸려가지고
눈이 머는 비극 속에서도
거대한 벽화 걸작을 완성한 뒤에
그 그림을 모두 태워버리라는
유언 하나만 남긴 채
생을 마감하게 됩니다
저는 이 작품에서 되게 좋아하는
대목이 있는데
많은 사람들이 스트리그랜드 찾아가서 묻는 거예요
어 너 정말 그림을 그리는데
그림을 그리고 싶은 거야?
그랬더니 어 나는 정말로 그림을 그리고 싶소
라고 얘기를 하니까
아니 근데 당신은 원래
성공한 직장인이었잖아
증권 중개인이었잖아
근데 지금 화가가 된다고 해도
기껏해야 3류밖에 될 수가 없어
근데 왜 하려고 하는 거야
라고 하니까
나는 물에 빠진 사람이야
물에 빠졌는데 헤엄을 잘 치고 못 치고가
무슨 소용이 있어
그냥 헤엄을 치는 거지
라고 얘기를 하거든요
네 그것을 추구하게 된
이 스트리그랜드의
거의 광기에 어린 예술적인 집착을
그리고 있는 작품이 바로
달과 육펜스입니다
그러니까 너무 설명을 잘하셔서
굳이 뭐 읽고 안 와도 될 정도로
이거 괜히 읽었네요
괜히 읽은 것 같은데요
이거를 혜진님이 간지님의
테마 책으로 골라주신 이유가
있다면 뭘까요?
그냥 저희가 생각하기에 편집자는
그 아티스트의 옆에서
작가의 옆에서
원고를 책으로 만들어주도록
돕는 스탭의 역할이잖아요
근데 이제
간지님은 아티스트이시니까
이런 작품을 읽었을 때
공감을 하실지
아니면 공감은 못해도 멋있다고
생각하시는지 아니면 완전 별로라고
생각하시는지 이런 것들이 궁금했어요
일단은
저는 공감을 하는데
스트링랜드 자체가
예술을 쫓을 때
너무
호들갑스럽게 쫓거든요
그래요?
가지고 있던 직장도 다 버리고
와이프 아들
애들 신경 안 쓰고
돈도 몇 푼 안 지고서
파리로 간 다음에 그것만 계속 그리는 거예요
갑자기 예술병에 걸린
계기가 있어요?
그건 없는데
근데 원래부터 하고 싶은 마음은 있었는데
40살 때까지 이제 생계 때문에
현실 때문에 증권
거래사로 일을 했던 거고
근데 왜 밥을 안 먹어요?
돈이 없어요
돈을 벌었다며
다 놔두고 왔어요
조금 갖고 오지
내 말이 그 말이야
먹은 것도 갖고 와야지
유두리 깨야 할 거 아니야
밥을 먹으면서 해야지 그림을 그릴 거 아니야
그림밖에 모르는 바보인 줄
그건 이상하네
그런 부분은 공감은 못하고
그리고 스트링랜드 입장에서 봤을 때는
와 너는 어떻게
왜 그렇게 사냐
너 진짜 머리에 무가 든 거야
계속 들어왔던 얘기입니다
그러니까 이런 우리가
뭘 그런 얘기를 들었다고요?
그러니까 뭐
너 그거 해서 돈 벌 수 있겠냐
그리고
심지어 요즘에는 예술을 하는
분들이
저에게도 많이 물어봐요
형 어떻게 해야지
이거 하면 돈 벌어먹고 살 수 있어요?
근데 저도 모르겠는데
왜냐면 처음부터 돈 벌려고
한 게 아니거든요
그래서 그 바다에
빠져서 헤엄을 계속 친다는 것처럼
저는 오히려
중독 도파민 중독자에
가까운 거예요
그냥 이런 음악이나 다른 일들을 다 할 때
너무 재밌으니까
다른 것
보다 이게 제일 재밌어서
하는 거거든요
이거를 달리라는 어떤 굉장히
순수한 거에 표현을 했다는 게
저는 좀 다릅니다
오히려 훨씬 순수한 욕망일 수도 있고
아 배고파
밥 먹고 싶다
이런 것처럼
저번에 그때 그 연주 진짜 재밌었는데
한 번 더 하고 싶다
그때 만든 거 진짜 재밌었는데
한 번 더 만들어 보고 싶다
뭐 이런 욕망에 좀 더 가까운 게 아닐까
싶은 거고
내가 내 욕망을 충족시키는데
돈을 안 준다고
찡찡대는 건 좀
그렇잖아요
근데 이제
회사원분들은
우리들
야
너 하고 싶은 거 해서 좋겠다
나는 맨날 사대보험
힘들어
아유 나도
내 꿈을 찾아가고 싶어
하는데
그럼 니 해보던가
이거는 사실
달과 6펜스라기보다 요즘 세상은
달과
6만 달러
느낌이거든요
왜냐면 달이 아닌 걸 선택했을 때는
정말 풍요롭게 살 수 있는 게
정해져 있고
저는
공감 가는 부분도 있지만
공감이 안 되는 부분도 있다
저는 많은 분들하고
이거를 읽어봤는데
이 작품에 그렇게 공감 간다고
얘기하신 분은 사실 저는 처음인 것 같아요
저도 처음 봐요
회사원분들끼리
맞아요
왈자?
왈자 왈자
왈자들이랑 또 해보면은
아니 그래서
독후감을 써오셨다고
들었는데 같이 읽어볼 수 있나요?
저 써왔어요
진짜로?
낭독해주시는 거예요?
독후감
김간지
12월
날씨 맑음
주변에 예술을 하는 친구들이나
또는 세상에 노출된 예술가를 보면
어쩌면 한 번씩은
이런 말을 하거나
혹은 생각 정도 해본 적은 있으실 겁니다
그거에서 밥 벌어먹고
살 수 있냐
하지만 찰스 스트링랜드는
여러분에게 얘기하죠
신경 쓰지 말고 꺼져
저는 이렇게 얘기하고 싶습니다
걱정되면
돈이 나죠
달과 6펜스를 읽어보시고
주변의 예술가들에게
따스한 밥 한 끼를
대접해 주십시오
그들이 여러분의 아내나 남편을
빼앗을지라도
진짜 잘 쓴다
아니 그 무슨 라디오
30초 광고 이런 거 같아요
달과 6펜스 광고로 쓰고 싶어요 진짜
저희 민수야
곧 멍씁니다
양념 아주 맛있게 먹어버릴 거예요
잘 먹는데 잘 먹어
감상을 너무 얘기를 잘해주셔서
바로 밸런스 게임으로 넘어가도 될 거 같은데요
밸런스 게임을 준비를
해주셨다고 해요
한 번 같이 볼 수 있을까요?
월급 반토막인데 하고 싶은 일을 하는 것
vs
연봉 2배
저희는 연봉 2배 선택해요
저도 연봉 2배
아 그래요?
연봉 2배하고 그냥 하고 싶은 걸 따로 하면 되지 않나
그럼 되잖아
아 그러세요?
월급 반토막이 난대요 혜진님
저러면 돈이 없잖아요
하고 싶은 걸 하는 일이
시간이 좀 적어질지라도
연봉 2배를 받으면서 하는 게 좋고
저는 이제 나름대로
달을 충분히 쫓았으니까
이제는 6펜스 쪽으로
다 꺾어서
역 스트릭 랜드를 하는 거죠
오직 돈만 보면
하기 싫은 일을 하면서 연봉 2배를
빠르게 치고 빠지겠다
근데 여러분 좀 잘못 생각하는 게 있는데
뭐든 하고 싶은 일은
돈과 결부되면
하기 싫은 일로 바뀌어요
그것도 맞는 말이에요
그러니까 완전히 원초적으로
제가 순수하게 좋아했던 일이
돈 때문에 어쨌든 하게 되면은
스트레스를 동반할 수 밖에 없습니다
제가 생각하는 현대 사회에서 돈을 받으면은 스트레스를 동반할 수 밖에 없습니다
그래서 돈은 스트레스랑
비례할 수 밖에 없다고 생각을 해요
원래 돈 주는 일은 다 하기 싫은 거 아닌가요?
원래 어느 정도 서비스를
제공해야 되는 거고 그게
저는 토스 빼고는 다 하기 싫어요
네 넘어가겠습니다
두 번째
평생 누구에게도 이해 못 받는
천재로 살기 vs
누구나 나에게 공감해주는
범인 평범한 사람으로 살기
저는 천재
허키님은요?
별...
일단 별 그렇게 공감이 안 되는
누구나 공감이 되는 천재로 살고 계시다고요
아예 상관이 없어요
지금 이미 천재로 살고 있어서?
이러나 저러나 별 상관 없을 것 같아요
쇼미 심사위원이라서?
이렇게 되면 이렇게 살겠고
이렇게 되면 저렇게 살겠고 할 것 같은데
혜진님은 어떠세요?
저는 평생 누구에게도 이해 받지 못해도
한 번 내가
천재라고 생각하고 살고 싶어요
저도요 너무 짜릿할 것 같아요
아침에 눈 뜰 때마다
그걸 어떻게 알아요? 본인만?
저는 아는 것 같아요
그건 지금도 할 수 있어요
지금도 얼마든지 할 수 있잖아요
그게 어려워요
그게 왜 어렵죠?
자기 전에 열 번 외치고 살고
나는 천재다
그게 어려운 이유가 뭐예요?
천재가 아니니까
아닌 걸 본인이 아니까
아니 그거는
그냥 맞다고 믿으면 되지
자기 신뢰의 문제예요
자기 신뢰가 어려운 건가요?
맞아 자기 신뢰가 어려워요
신뢰적이지 않은 사람들이라는 거죠
맞는 말일 수 있어요
제가 옛날에는 이런 말을 들으면
진짜 슬펐던 시기가 있었거든요
저한테도
대학생 때만 해도 뭔가
자기 확신을 엄청 갈구했었던
시기가 있었어요
그리고 뭔가 저한테 달이라고 하면
어떤 직업이라던가
예술 이런 건 아니지만
뭔가 막연하게
달을 쫓았던 시기가
누구에게나 있잖아요
그 외에 기피의 강요라는
파트라크 지스킨트의 소설이 있어요
파트라크 지스킨트 소설에서
주인공이
화가인데
유산균이에요?
우유 이름 아닌가요?
그 말을 좀 참을 수는 없었어요
나도 파스트라가 떠올랐는데
참는 게 지성인이잖아요
제 신뢰가 너무 두껍기 때문에
누군가는 말해줘야 된다라는 믿음이 있었어요
저는 참고 있었어요
근데 왜 말했어?
말하더라고
하여튼 그 사람이
주인공이 화가인데
어느 날 평론가가 이 사람에 대해서
이렇게 한 줄 평을 한 거예요
재능은 반짝이지만 기피가 없다
그래서 제목이 기피의 강요거든요
그 한 줄을 본 순간
완전히 거기에 매여서
깊이, 깊이란 뭘까
깊이 있는 작품은 어떤 걸까
라고 고민을 하면서 파멸해 가는 얘기예요
근데 저는 이 작품이
저는 되게
열심히 읽었고 공감했던 게
이렇게 누군가 권위가 있는 사람
나에 대해서
평가할 수 있다라고 생각하는 사람
매 한마디가
너무 그 당시에는
영향력이 커서
자기 확신을 갖는다는 게
그게 정말 대단하신 것 같아요
깊이에 가스라이팅이 있습니다
뭘 하든 간에
아 근데 걘 좀 깊이가 없지 않나?
이러면은
어느 순간 깊이가 없는 사람이 돼버리는 거예요
깊이를 그럼 누가 정할 수 있어요?
수치화 할 수 있나요?
아니면 그냥 어차피 예술이라는 거
결국에 개인이 느끼는
그런 감정들일 텐데
어 깊이 몰라? 퉁쳐버리는 게
훨씬 더 현명하게
좀 나은 미래로 갈 수 있는
방향이라는 생각은 있어요
그 깊이 가스라이팅이라는 말이
되게 공감이 가는 게
깊이라는 말이 이상하게
주관적인데 객관적으로 느껴져요
어 맞아요
깊이라는 말은 마치 잴 수 있는
측정 가능한 모인 것 같잖아요
그 깊이가 없다라는 말은
그 사람의 주관적인 판단일 수 있다는 것을
알면서도 이상하게
그 말이 가진 힘이 되게 객관적인
평가처럼 들려서 약간
바뀌는 것 같아요
근데 또 깊이가 없는 사람도 있습니다
음
이게 깊이의 오류거든요
그리고 민경님 같은 경우에 가끔
개인기를 막 준비해 와요
그래서 뭐 허키 랩을 막 연습해 온다든지
깊이가 없어요
거기에 대해서
왜요 왜요
딱 봐도 깊이가 없잖아요
아니 말을 그렇게 하냐
깊이가 없습니다
근데 저는 그때 허키 랩을 했을 때
내가 예술을 하겠다
이게 아니었어요
예의 차원에서 준비한 거예요
라임이 맞네요
예술이 아닌 예의였다
예술 앞에서 그게 예의라고 생각할 수 있나요
아니 나는 그러면 기뻐할 거라서
솔직히 말해서
내가 미안해요
내가 힙합 프로듀오를 처음 만나봐요
그래서 나는 그거를
한 수줄로 준비해 오는 게 예의인 줄 알았어요
그래서 내가 첫 촬영 끝나고
제가 사실은 첫 촬영 때
명작영화 월드컵 때 그걸 하려다
타이밍이 없어서
촬영 끝나고 내려가서
아 맞다 제가 이거 준비했는데 하고
랩을 한 수줄로 했어요 그랬더니
아 그런 일이 있었구나 맞네
진짜 진지하게
그래서 집에 가서 몇 번 더 해봤어요
어 좀 부족했나 여러분
그렇게 오류를 겪고서
깊이가 생겨났는데
그럼 더 근본적인 질문을 해봐도 돼요
네
허키님한테 달은 뭐예요
에?
어떤
정말 도달하고자 싶은
어떤 이상 예술적인 이상
그러게요
있어요
생각 안 해본 것 같은데 갑자기
그냥 그 순간 재밌게 하면은
저는 그냥
그 이상을 생각 못해요
재미
허키가 말하는 재미에는
재미에는 사실 많은 것들이 포함이 되어 있습니다
그러겠죠
그러니까 뭐 이게 사람들과 같이 노는 것도
될 수 있고
재미라는 게 뭐
멋도 있을 수도 있고 뭔가 또 자극을
다른 사람을 자극시킬 수도 있고
영감을 줄 수도 있고
여러 가지가 있는데 재미있는
뭐가 됐든 그냥 재미있게 할 수 있는
어떤 것 그게 뭐 특별히
뭔지는 모르겠으나
그러니까 뭐 대단하면 뭘 쫓지 않아요 저는
안고 있어요 지금은
그러니까 가끔 사람들이
일생일대 역작을 만들겠다
라고 생각하잖아요 예술가들이
뭐 그런 분들도 있겠지만
요즘
좋긴 할 것 같긴 한데
그거를 특별히 막 생각하면서
해야 돼 막 다 버려
나병 걸려
이런 건 없어요 솔직하게 말씀드리면
근데 그 무목적성이 사실은
좀 부럽다고 생각했어요
왜냐면 대부분 저희 같은
직장인들은
뚜렷한 목적이 있어서
뭐죠 목적이
돈이죠 돈
아 물론 저도 돈 때문에 할 때도 많아요
그런데 진짜 그냥 완전 확실하게 계약을 해서
여덟 시간을 일하잖아요
출퇴근을 하면서
그게 이제 좀
나의 어떤 주체성을
일정 부분 많이
찾아갔다고 느끼고 대부분의 직장인들은
어딘가에 매여있다는 거
사실 자체가 사실은
어떤 나의 일부분을 상실해간다는 느낌이 있거든요
그게 없다는 게
좀 부럽긴 하네요
듣다 보니까
돈 주는 일은 그런 거 있어요
돈받고 하는 일은
내가 뭔가 갉아먹히고 있다는 기분이 들
때가 많죠
아무리 이게 음악이고 예술이고 해도
그거를 좀 누르고
이 사람들 말을 들어줘야 되는 거니까
그거 누르는 거를
저희는 매일
아침 7시부터
매일 가슴에 돌 같은 걸 얹고 다니는 거
매일매일
비교적 저희는 좀 저는 덜
덜 누르겠죠 아무래도
근데 아마 저희보다 한 4배 더 버실 겁니다
훨씬 더 안정적으로
돈이 문제입니다 사실
모든 것들에서
예술이라는 거에 대해서
고가치적으로
평가하고 이런 것도
자본주의 세상이
돈벌이 없으면 사람 취급 안 하니까 문제인 거죠
좀 너무 정치적이었나
그러면 이것도 저는 사실 좀 궁금한데요
업계에
오랜 시간 계시면서 되게 다양한
아티스트들 보셨잖아요
흥방성쇠를 보셨을 텐데
그 예술적
재능이라는 게 타고나는 거라고
생각하세요 아니면 그냥 끝까지
안 놓는 사람이 이기는 거라고
생각하세요? 왜냐면 여기서 스트링랜드도
마흔 살이 갑자기 전향을
하지만 결국 대작가가 된다는
것이 되게
우리가 천재한테 갖는
어떤 환상 같은 거를 대변하고 있다고
생각하거든요 그니까 그 재능
그 재능은
그 사람 안에 숨겨져 있어서
40년 동안 빛나지 않았더라도
결국엔 빛났어
이 질문 되게 많이 하잖아요
노력이 먼저냐 인내력이 먼저냐
이거 자체가 진짜
이상한 질문인 것 같아요 왜냐면은
이 질문 자체가
결과
중심적인 어떤 그거를
문제로 깔고 하는 얘기잖아요
이 사람이 뭐 피카소가 있어 이 사람이 되게
잘 됐으니까 이 사람 원래부터 천재고
원래부터 그렇기 때문에 이 사람은
재능이 엄청나게 있는 사람이고
그런 사람이다 안 그런 사람도
인내하면 그렇게 될 수도 있고 아닐 수도
있는데 일단 재능이 있는지 봐야
뭐 이거잖아요 지금
이거 자체가 그냥 성공을
전제해 둔 거잖아요 결말적으로
이 사람 결론적으로 잘 되느냐 마느냐
이 사회에서 돈을 벌 수 있느냐
마느냐 이거를 따지는 문제인데
제가 생각할 때는 그냥
예술은 그냥 돈
안 벌어도 되거든요
그냥 취미로 그냥 예를 들어서
기타 치고 싶다 이런 거 뭐 기타 사갖고
띵땅띵땅 거리고
뭐 회사 다녀서 돈 벌고
이럴 수 있는 문제잖아요
그니까 이거를 너무
경제 활동이랑 너무
사회적인 인정이라든가
그리고 이기구 지구의
게임 안에서 이거를 자꾸 해석
하다 보니까 저런 얘기를 하게 되는 것 같아요
근데 저는
기준이 전부 너무 좀 세속적일 때가 있어요
그러니까 결론적으로 저는
재능이 있고 없고
뭐
인내를 해서 뭐 잘하면
뭐 성공할 수 있고
요거 자체가
의미없게 느껴지는 거죠
어떻게
하고 싶은 걸 하면서 살면 되겠지
뭐 그런 생각이
제가 생각하는 재능은
내가 만약에 무슨 기타를 처음
잡아는데
아니 이게 왜 이렇게 재밌지라고 하는 게
저는 좀 재능이라고 생각하거든요
어 이거
계속 쳐도 재밌네
막 무슨 뽕 맞은 것처럼
어 너무 재밌다 매일매일 해도 재밌다
자는데도 기타 생각이 나고 또 재밌다
그거는 사실 좀
타고나야 되는 거라고 생각해요
근데 아무나 붙잡아놓고
자 오늘부터 너는 하루에 6시간씩
기타를 쳐야 돼
투덜투덜 대면서 하긴 하겠죠
그러면은 결국에 결과값으로 봤을 때는
그 사회에서 말하는 실패할 확률이
좀 높죠
좀 높고 한단 말이에요 근데 참고 연습해라
인내해라
군대도 아니고
뭐 그래서 뭐가 될 것 같지는 않아요
스티븐 킹의 유혹하는 글쓰기
아까 추천해주신 그 책에도
정확하게 같은 얘기가 나오는데
그 사람한테 재능이 있는지를 알아보려면
그 사람이
연습해야 되는 시간동안에만 하면
재능이 없는 거다
스티븐 킹이 자기 아들 얘기하면서 그랬는데
섹스폰이었나 그거
너무 재밌으면 분명히 그 시간을 넘어서
그냥 한다
그걸로 재능을 알 수 있다라고 얘기를 하더라고요
되게 같은 얘기를 하셔서 놀랐어요
두 분 얘기 들어보니까 결국에는
재미를 느끼고 즐기고
좋아하는 그 마음 자체가 재능이라고 할 수 있겠네요
재능이라는 게 만약에 있다면
그렇다고 저는 생각해요
뭘 또 할 수 있고
그럼 마무리하면서
스트릭랜드에게 해주고 싶은 말이 있다면
한 마디씩 해주시죠
스트릭랜드
동년배잖아요
그래도
철구 왔으면 됐잖아
오
멋지다
왜요?
이 책 완전히 빠져서 읽고 오신 것 같아요
완전 푹 빠져서 읽으셨네요 책을
아니요 안 빠졌는데요
그렇게 쑥스러워서
틱틱대는 것까지가 되게 소년 같아요
맞아요
감사합니다
다음 책은 뭐죠 간지님?
두 번째 책은
브람스를 좋아하세요
아 이거 저
읽었다고 할 수 있죠
이거를 맡긴 거잖아요
저의 숙제였죠 이것이
혜진님이 이걸 추천을 했는데
무슨 책인지 좀
소개해드릴 수 있나요?
이거는
고전을 사실 되게 어렵게 생각하시는
분들 굉장히 많으시잖아요
그런 분들한테 항상 인문적으로 추천하는
소설이에요 왜냐하면
로맨스의 고전이기도 하면서
삼각관계의 어떤 근본
원조 맛집이라고 할 만한
소설이거든요 이 소설이 지금
주인공은 39세의 여성이자
인테리어 업자인 폴인데요
이 폴에게는 굉장히
오래된 남자친구가 있습니다
이 로제는 폴을
사랑하면서도 사랑하지 않는 건 아니에요
사랑하면서도 이상하게
다른 여성들과의
하룻밤의 가벼운 관계를
버리지 못하는 생활을 계속
반복하는 거예요
이런 로제와의 권태로운 관계를
끊지도 못하고
어떻게 하지도 못하고 이어가고 있었는데
어느날 새로
인테리어를 해야 되는 집에 갔다가
그 집의 아들인
25살 청년
시몽을 만나게 돼요
근데 이 25살의 변호사인 이 청년이
폴에게 한눈에 반해서
거의 숭배에 가까운
구애를 하는 거죠 그래서 폴은 고민 끝에
이 시몽과의 만남을 시작을 해봅니다
그러니까 잘생기고
나만 좋아하고 다 좋은데
근데 이제 시몽만 만나고 오면
이상하게 피곤하고 몸에 힘이
빠지는 거예요 왜냐하면
이 시몽의
기쁨 그리고 에너지 이게 좀
부담스럽기도 하고
기 빨린다 그러죠
그리고 맞아요 기도 빨리고
그 첫사랑의 열정에 들떠있는
이 시몽의 모습이 어떻게 보면
그 누군가를 사랑하는
스스로에게 빠져있는게 아닐까
라고 생각할 정도로
그 폴의 마음과 약간 온도차가 있는 겁니다
그래서 결국 폴은
아 내 오래된 연인
로제와의 관계에서 느꼈던
어떤 익숙한 슬픔
익숙한 배신감 익숙한
절망이 더 나에게 어울리는 것은
아닐까 하는 생각을
하면서 양손에 시몽과
로제를 놓고 고민을 하게 됩니다
과연 이 사랑의 미친
삼각관계에서 나라면 어떤
선택을 하게 될까 이렇게 끝까지
이입해서 읽게 되는 작품이
바로 브람스를 좋아하세요 입니다
재밌네요
책 왜 삽니까
책 사서 뭐하나 대충 이렇게
안돼 안돼 사
시민들 책 사야 되는구나
자 그러면 이번에
허키님이 써온
독후감이 있다고
아 없어요 독후감은 없고 저의 감상평을 간단하게
감상평
감상평이라기보다 이 브람스를 좋아하세요
를 숙제를 받게 된
다음에 저한테 벌어진 일
네 좋습니다
그 여정 그 여정
그 여정을
일단 좀 얘기를 해볼게요
자 일단 작가님
으로부터 전달을 받았죠
혜진님이 나한테
브람스
브람스를 좋아하세요
를 읽어와라
라고 숙제를 주셨다
저 딱 보고 천만다행이라고 생각했습니다
세상에 나한테
이런 불행한 일이
일단 이런 일이
생겨서 어 그렇지만 뭐
이유가 있겠거니 하고
한 30%쯤 읽었을 때
깊은 고민에 빠집니다
하트할까 하트할까
이거 계속 가야할까
이분이 나한테
왜 이러셨지
거부할까 이거 어떻게 해야 되지
그래서 아 좀만 더 참아볼까
어떻게 해야지 그때 말씀
그때 이제 작 피님한테
아 이거 제가 더 이상 읽을 수 있을지
잘 모르겠어요
이렇게 말했는데 그래도 한번 참고 읽어보시라
그래서 제가
70%인데 그래 한번 가보자
이러면서 또 읽었죠
한 80%쯤에 다행히
어 이거 언제쯤 끝나 할 때 쯤에
다음 페이지 딱 하니까 작품 해설로 딱 넘어가
어
긴 여정을
아
방금 이렇게 설명해 주셨잖아요
방금 내용 설명해 주셨잖아요 제가
간단하게 다시 설명해 드리면은
폴이란 여자가 있어요
프랑스에 살아요
졸라 멀리
프랑스에 사는 폴이란 여자가 있는데
로제란 남친이 있어요
근데 이 폴이
이 시몽한테 잠깐 한눈을 판거에요
근데 어떻게 됐냐면요
결말에
이 폴이
로제한테 그냥 돌아가요
결말에
대반전
대박사건
우와 이런 엄청난 사건이
이거 너무 많이 벌어지는 일이잖아요
이 세상에
뭔가 더 뭐가 더 있어야 되나
총이 나와야 되는 느낌
사실 근데 모든 로맨스 소설이
아까 허키님이 요약하신 것처럼
요약하면
다 그런 얘기에요 만나고 헤어지고
또 다른 사람 만나고
근데 이 로맨스 소설이
존재하는 이유는
얼마나 이 내용에
몰입이 되도록 심리 묘사를
그 삼각관계 안에서
방황하는
여성 주인공 폴의 심리를
기가 막히게 묘사했기 때문에
어떤 장면에서
시작부터 몰입이 싹 되죠
그 남봉꾼
오래된 남친을 만나러 가면서
느껴지는 회안
로제씨
너무 익숙하고
권태로운데 라디오로 탁 켜서
라디오를 들으면서 운전해서 가잖아요
그때 느끼는 폴의 심정이
뭔지 너무 알겠는거에요
딱 나한테 맞는
그 주파수의 라디오를
말하지 않아도 켜주는
어떤 그 존재
근데 심홍차를 탈 때는
폴이 심홍은 처음
만나는 사람이니까
심홍차를 탈 때는
차의 이 너비가 안 익숙해서
스타킹몰이 쫙 나가요
아 그 섬세한 어떤 연출이 다 있네요
익숙함과 낯선
그런거를 음미하면서 읽으면
와 진짜 이거는 명작이다
그렇지만 저는 그
운전하면서 욕하면서 들었겠죠
뭐야?
저는 그 하루하루 현실에 치여 살고 있는
40대 남자잖아요
내가 스타킹이
찢어지든 말든
내가 저 여자 스타킹이 어떻게 찢어져서
시트가 불편하면
자세를 고쳐 앉으라고
내가 굳이 신경쓸 때까지
이게 내가
정확히 오늘 오면서
보고 싶었던 그림이라서
너무 행복해
로제한테 뭐
아 뭐 이렇게
어쩌라고
만나고 안 해줘
주접치지 말고 헤어져
여러분이 킹받는다고 하셨던
제목에도 그런 심리가
숨겨져 있는데
맨날 저희한테 독자문의가 들어와요 왜냐하면
하세요? 왜 물음표가 아니고
이 말줄임표 3개냐
이렇게 물어보시는데
사실 여기에 작가의 의도가 숨겨져 있는 건데
잠깐 그 의도조차
저는
의도가 있을 것 같거든요
네
그거를 알고 싶지도 않은 기분은
뭔지 아세요?
그것조차 거부하고 싶은 기분은 뭔지 아세요?
알겠으니까 셧업 이러고 싶은
사강씨
알겠는데요 적당히 하세요 적당히 하세요
그러면 그 대사는 어땠어요?
다시 한 번 알려주세요
그 대사는 어땠어요?
당신에게 고독형을 선고합니다
이 새끼가
되게 사랑꾼이시라고 들었어요
아니 근데
이건
혜진님 잠깐만요
이 책에서는
이 진정한
사랑이고 나발이고를 논할 껀덕지가
사실은 제가 느낄 때
아예 없거든요 이 세명의 이야기가
이 얘네들이 하는 거는
그냥 연애지
장난치는거지 이거는
맞잖아요
길 못 찾는 쥐가 보기에는
이건 장난같은 거예요
뭔가 끈끈한 부부관계에 비하면
옵션이 되게 많고
뭘 해도 되는 상황이잖아요
뭘 해도 안된다는 건 아니지만
진정한 사랑은 무조건
완벽한 커뮤니티가 있어야
이런 얘기가 아니고
너무 가볍잖아요
얼마나 진지해요
지금 고민이
진지하게 한다
폴도 고민해 진짜 고민되겠죠
폴도 글러먹었어요
폴은
여자 주인공 이름이 폴이에요
글러먹었다기보다
저 정도야 뭐 얼마든지 있을 수 있는 일이고
근데 심용은
순수하게 사랑을 하잖아요
걔도 지금 정신없어요 지금
나도 저 시대를
거쳐온 사람이라서 알아요
다 이 세 명의 감정이 뭔지도
대충 알겠고
다 알겠는데
진짜 주접떨지 말고
주접이다
내일 할 일이나 걱정해라
먹고 살리라
지금 인생이 그렇게 호락호락하지 않고
돈이 안 필요한다고 하는 분들이
왜 아저씨가
먹고 살 걱정이라면서
밥은 먹어야 될 거 아니야 연애 짓거리 그만하고
갑자기 일이 손이 안 잡히는데 어떡해요
이게 해결이 안되면
일이 손이 안 잡히는 게 어디 있어요
지금 나와서 그래
이거 프랑스에서 저기 기군
지금 나와서 이러는 거야 이거 다
생긴 건 멀쩡해 생겨갖고 말이야
벌써부터 나이 많은 여자만
찾잖아요
근데 여러 가지 시도해보는 건
오케이 젊었을 때
해볼 수 있어
여기저기 해볼 수 있는데
갑자기
큰아버지처럼 말씀하세요
근데 너 공략 잘해야 된다
너 어떻게 될지 모르는 거야
진짜 이거 물장난이야
로제씨도
로제씨도 너무 비겁해
로제는 완전 남분꾼이잖아요
잠깐만요
폴은 아니야?
폴은 진지한 고민하고 있잖아요
로제도 그럴 수 있어요
여기서 폴이랑 로제랑 다른 게 뭐예요?
좀 비슷하다고 생각해요
똑같잖아요
그렇긴 하지
너무 재밌네
근데 어쨌든 익숙한 것과
새로운 것 사이에서 고민하는
이 심리를 이 정도로
잘 묘사한 작품이 저는 별로 없다고 생각해서
저도
확실합니까 지금?
저희 같은 문학소녀들한테는
어머
이런 일이
이게 뭐 그런 거에 원형이다 이럴 순 있겠죠
사실 이 소설의 대목은
어느 쪽으로도 확 넘어가지 않은 상태에서
밀고 당길 때
그때 약간 묘미가 있는 게
이 불함수를 조사하세요 라는
사실 이 제목도
물어보거든요
심옥이
불함수를 좋아하세요 이렇게
요즘으로 치면
아 피곤해
연주회 같이
연주회를 보러 가요
불함수를 좋아하세요
그래서
폴이 생각하는 거예요
불함수를 좋아하세요 쩜쩜쩜
내가 불함수를 좋아했던 거
모차르트 언니
누가 나한테 이런 질문을
최근에 한 적이 언제였더라
그게 근데 너무
맞아 로맨틱한
묘미 문학적 묘미
왜냐면 불함수라는 예술가가
내가 원래 모르는 예술가인데
좋아하세요 라고 물었을 때
낯선 세계로
사실은 넘어가 볼까
하는 그 말의
어떤 비유가
불함수에요
불함수를 좋아하세요가 제목이 아니라
불함수를 좋아하세요 쩜쩜쩜이 제목이 아니라
제목인 이유는
본인한테 하는 말이
내가 좋아했던가
누가 나한테 이런 질문을 한 게
정말 얼마 만인가
이게 다 연애를 못해봐서 그렇습니다
지지고 벗고 서로 막
왜 저러는 거야
내 말은
연애 그렇게 하는 거 아닌데
이게 솔직히 더 유치하네
이것도 잘못됐지만
이제 2026년에
추적된 스토리들이 많이 있을 거 아니야
그런 내러티브
스토리라면 그렇다고 볼 수 있겠지만
전혀 벗어나는 것들이
많지 않거든요
다른 스토리랑 비슷한 것도 있고
그렇지만 또 해설을 듣고 나니
과연 그런 것들이 있었구나
내가 몰랐던
그러면 밸런스 게임을
또 몇 개 준비했다고 하는데요
오마이갓
한번 해볼게요
이건 뭐야
인스타그램을
아예 안 하는 애인데
인스타그램에서 온갖 계정 밈 다 섭렵하는
애인
아니 저는 이래도 좋고 저래도 좋고
저 외모는 오른쪽이 좋거든요
이쪽이 좀 더 괜찮은 거 같아요
근데 인스타그램은 안 하는 애인이 좋은 거 같아요
저도 안 하는 애인
저는 둘 다 상관없어요
넘어갈게요
맞춤법 자주 틀리고 어휘력이 부족한데 착한 사람
이거 어디 네이버 블로그에서
아 이상한
질문 수준이
이거 왜 이러는 거야
이게 완전 발작 버튼이네
소금칩 미꾸라지처럼
팔딱팔딱 뛰네
매일매일 이런 것만 하면 안 돼요 진짜 재밌다
맞춤법 자주 틀리고 어휘력이 부족
아니 이게 뭔 상관이야
말끝마다 지적하고 가르치려 듣는
뇌쌩남
이건 닭전
저도 착한 사람
맞춤법 틀리는 거 전 상관없어요
너가 내 평생의
발 여자야 뭐 이런 거
괜찮아요 착하게
심성만 고우면
언어는 거칠어도 저는 상관없어요
근데 저는
개인적으로 이 후자가
저를 제일 제일 열받게 만들려면
이렇게 후자처럼 하면 되거든요
가르치려 듣는
뇌쌩남? 네
저는 말끝마다 지적하고 가르치려 듣는 거는
당연히 싫고
심지어는 발음이 좋은 것도 싫어요
약간
뭐예요 그건 또
맞춤법 자주 틀리고 어휘력이 부족하고
약간 어느란
혜진이가 좋아요
이런 거예요?
또렷하면 싫은 거예요
알지나요
언어 능력이 너무 좋으면
브람스 좋아하세요?
브람스
그게 아니고
이런 질문 하지 마요
언어 능력이 너무 좋으면
그러니까 혜진이가 하는 말은
말을 너무 매끈매끈하게 잘하고
발성도 좋고 막
프레젠테이션 되게 잘하는
너무 뚜렷뚜렷한 사람인데
이런 사람 진짜 싫다는 거죠
아 그렇죠
왜냐면 그건 제가 이제 계속 문과로
나오고
이렇게 외국어를 전공하고 하다보니까
주변에 있는 남자 사람 친구들이
다 그런 이여서
그렇게 되면 너무 약간 친구처럼 느껴지고
오히려 약간 새로운 느낌이
저도 말주변이 부족한 사람이
늘 너무 귀엽다고 생각해요
너무 귀엽잖아요
브람스
자 그럼
허킹님께 마지막으로
제가 생각하는 사랑이란?
몰라
그래도 너무 지금 두 분이
질색하고 있긴 하지만
혜진님은 이게
로맨스 소설의 고전인 이유라
이 두 분 말고 어떤 분들이 읽으면 좋을지
추천의 한마디를 해주신다면
근데 저는
아까 제가 말씀드렸던 것처럼
사실 서사는 뻔하거든요
어떻게 변주하느냐의 문제에요
근데 어쨌든
저는 공감하니까
고전의
이 로맨스 소설을 읽어보시면
아 이런 말맛으로
이런 문장으로 이렇게 사랑을 묘사할 수도 있구나
정말 기가 막힌데
아 너무나 문장들이 예쁘고
절묘하다라는 걸
느끼실 수 있을 것 같아서
좀 이해하는 게
저도 어릴 적에
제육떡밥에 꽂혀가지고
지역별로 제육떡밥 맛있다는데
다 찾아다녔었거든요
이런 거 같아요
아주머니의 손맛과
아주머니의 뿌리는
양념에 따라서 같은 제육이래요
어차피 제육인데 맞아요
로맨스는 제육떡밥이구나
정확해
진짜 창작기까지 사랑은
제육방람기행이에요
올해도 제육맛 알아요
근데 매일 먹어도
조금씩 달라져
양발 얼마나 볶았는지
너무 제가 디스를 해서
네 아니에요
제가 원하는데
너무 좋아요
허키님이 이렇게 열받아여서
진짜 너무 행복해요
악당들
책으로 사람 괴롭히는
한 번 맞아봐라
잘 봤습니다
다음 책 또 간지님이
진행을 좀 해주시죠
마지막 책은
냈다 이미 알고 있는 책입니다
인간실격인데요
이 인간실격
어떤 책인지 또
혜진님이
챗GPT AI스럽게
아니 말을 그렇게 해요?
뭐 어떻게 얘기했었어야 돼요?
AI보다 더 뛰어나게 지금 하고 있는데
그럼 그것보다 더 뛰어나게
유료 버전 느낌으로
프로 재미나이로
한 번 설명해주시죠
네 인간실격하면
사실은
인간실격의 내용을
소개하기보다는
주인공 요조라는 캐릭터를
설명하고 싶어요
이 인간실격의 주인공인 요조는
한마디로 말하면 익살꾼이에요
우리 주변에 한 명씩 있는
굉장히 익살이 많은
오락부장 같은 친구 있잖아요
친구들을 웃기기 위해서
막 광대짓도 하고
슬래스틱까지 선보이는 친구인데
이렇게 말하면 되게 유쾌한 친구라고
생각하실 수도 있겠지만
요조는 상처를 잘 받고
무한을 잘 타는 성격이에요
띰틀을 하다가 일부러 넘어지는
슬래스틱을 선보여요
모든 친구들이 막 배를 잡고
깔깔깔깔 웃는데
닷케이트라는 친구 한 명이 와가지고
귓속말을 하는 거예요
너 일부러 그랬지
근데 그때 이 문장이
요조한테 거의 사형선고나
다름없이 느껴졌다고 하거든요
근데 더 재밌는 건
이렇게 자기의 모습이 들통난 뒤에도
이 아이를 멀리하는 게 아니라
계속 그게 자기의 진심이라고
믿게 하고 싶어서
이 아이를 곁에 둘 정도로
타인의 시선을 극도로 두려워하는 사람
이게 바로 요조예요
근데 이제 요조의 인생에서
굉장히 여러 사람을 만나게 되는데
아주 중요한 사람이 바로
작품 후반에 등장하는 여자
요시코라는 여자거든요
근데 이 여자는 그냥
나를 무조건적으로 믿어주는 사람
나를 그냥 인간과 자체로 신뢰해주는 사람
이 여자다 라고 생각을 하고
이 여자와 결혼을 하고
가면 없는 삶을 꿈꾸는데요
이 요시코의
특수한 신뢰 때문에
끔찍한 사건이 발생하고
요조는 큰 충격을 받습니다
그리고 막 하늘을 향해 얘기하는 거예요
신뢰는 죄인가요?
사람이 사람을 믿는 게 죄인가요?
이때부터 요조의 삶은
술과 마약에 중독돼서
완전 진창 속에 빠지고요
자기 원래의 가족과도 절연당한 채
쓸쓸히 죽음만을 기다리는
인간 실격자가 되고 맙니다
이 요조라는 사람의 인생을
압축한 건데
어떻게 감히 잡히세요?
인간 쓰레기죠 사실
아까 왜 한숨을 쉬었냐면
제가 픽션으로 접한
인물 중에 최악의 인물입니다
제가 제일 싫어하는 스타일의 사람
어떤 면에서요?
완벽한 자기애성 성격장애를
갖고 있는 사람의 인생
그 사람의 시점에서
자기소설적인 소설을 쓰면
이렇게 나오겠구나라는 생각을 했어요
저는 좀 약간 다르게 생각했거든요
요조가 자기를 너무 사랑했다
라기 보다는 물론 그렇게
자의식 과잉인 부분은 있지만
자기애보다는
자기 혐오가
저는 그것조차
그것조차 변명으로 느껴지는 거예요
그렇게 자기를 혐오한다고
일단 깔아놓고 내 인간 실격했다
라고 해놓고서는
어떻게 단 한 번도 자기의 행동을
고치지 않지
어떻게 단 한 번도 자기 반성을 하지 않고
여기 나오는 모든 인물한테
피해만 주다가 소설이 끝나거든요
모든 인생을 다 망치고
이건 어떻게 생각하세요? 저는
자기 회피적인 사람이라고 생각해요
아예 극한의 회피
뭔가가 닥쳐왔을 때에는
어쨌든 다 도망가잖아요
부딪히는 게 없잖아
그게 딱 제가 볼 땐 자기애성
그러니까 자기를 사랑해서 그런 게 아니고
오히려
이게 너무 낮으니까
자기를 존중하는 마음 자체가
아예 바닥을 치니까
뭔가 말도 안 되는 소리를 해가면서
어떻게
어떻게 그걸 고치려는 마음을 안 갖는 건지
저는 모르겠어요
저는 이제까지는 인간 실격 읽으면서
요조라는 인물에 대해서
굉장히 비판적으로 생각을 했었는데
최근에 다시 읽으면서는
요조가 어느 정도 이해가 됐어요
되게 뭔가
남의 눈치를 보고
연기를 하고 이런 모습들이
사실은 내 안에도 있지 않나
라는 생각이 많이 들었거든요
특히 저는 요조가 어린 시절의 모습을
묘사할 때
그 아버지가 나에게 뭔가를 사주고 싶어 하는데
그 아버지가 나에게 사주는 기쁨을 주려고
그 기쁨을 주려고
그 기쁨을 느끼고 싶어 하는
기대에 부응하려고
갖고 싶지도 않은데
아버지가 사주려고 하는 거를
갖고 싶은 척을 하잖아요
막 수첩에 몰래 써놓고
근데 그런 마음들이
제가 되게 어렸을 때
산타가 없다는 거를 알았어요
근데 엄마 아빠가
제가 아직도 산타를 믿는
어린아이이길 바라는 것 같은
느낌을 느껴서
계속 산타를 믿는 척을
초등학교 5학년 때까지 했었거든요
근데 저는 예를 들면
제가 그렇게 실망을 시키고 싶지 않았던 사람들은
믿을만한 어른이었잖아요
그분들은 제가 실망을 시켰어도
저를 공격하지 않았을 거란 말이죠
근데
요조의 인생은
계속 내가 누군가에게 실망을 시키면
그 사람이 나한테
갑자기 본색을 드러내면서
관계를 무너뜨리는 행동을 했던 거예요
예를 들면 여기 나오는
호리키라는 친구가 있잖아요
그 호리키라는 친구는
내가 아들인 걸 알고
나를 벗겨먹으면서
술도 가르쳐주고 매춘도 가르쳐주고
즐거운 일이 있을 때 항상 나를 데리고 다녀요
근데 어느 날 내가 그런 방탕한 생활 때문에
아버지에게 절연당할 위기에 처하니까
아빠한테
부탁을 해볼까
어떻게 해볼까 하다가
진짜 고민을 하고 안 되겠다
그냥 아버지한테 부탁하지도 말고
혼자 살아야지 하고
호리키의 집을 처음 찾아가거든요
호리키는 나한테 그렇게 많이 밥을 얻어먹었는데
내가 호리키의 집을 찾아간 건 처음이었어요
근데 호리키의 집을 찾아가서
나 사실 아버지랑 이렇게
끝날 것 같아 라고 얘기하니까
갑자기 안색이 변하면서
너 아버지랑 끝이면
나 끝이야 라고 말하지도 않고
차라리 그렇게 말했으면 좋겠는데
내가 앉아있는 방석이
너 자꾸 그렇게 앉으면
방석 실올이 풀린다니까
라고 하면서 계속 나한테 못마땅한 기색을 드러내요
그리고 그때 호리키 엄마가
이렇게 무슨 팥죽이었나
를 내주시는데
이제까지 자기는 이 친구한테
이걸 처음 대접하면서도
아 호사스러운 거네
참 호사스럽네
이 팥죽을 먹는다니 라고 하면서
그렇게 생색을 내거든요
근데 이런 모습들이
내가 누군가를 실망시켰을 때
그 사람의 갑자기 본색이 변하는 모습을
확 보면서
저는 점점 더 그 익살이라는 두께를
두껍게 가면은
두껍게 하게 되지 않았을까
저는 요조가
오히려 스트링랜드보다 훨씬
예술가라는 생각이 있어요
그냥 이 자기
인생을 외줄타기로써
너무 예술적으로
순수하게 그거를
헤쳐나가는게 물론 말그대로
인간쓰레기죠
그 회피와 어떤
여러가지
성격장애들로써 해나가는데
저는
만약에 저한테 스트링랜드랑
요조중에 누구랑 얘기해볼래라고 하면
저는 요조랑 얘기해보고 싶을 것 같아요
그냥
외도라는 사람이
궁금하고
분명히 뭔가 재밌는게 나올 것 같은 느낌이 있죠
누구를 때리라 그러면 저는 요조를 때릴거에요
저는 이 소설을
진짜 재밌게 봐서 이렇게 얘기를 하는거에요
너무 재밌게 봤는데
실제로 이런 사람이 있어요
있죠
실제로도 많잖아요
계속 거기에 대입해서
너무 화를 내는구나
어떤 싫어하는 인간의 전형을 본 느낌이군요
진짜 그거에 완전
다 합쳐놓은 어떤 사람인 것 같아요
그래서
진짜로 겪으면 돌아버리거든요
옆에서 보고 있으면
이 성인 예술병중에
이게 최악이에요
최악이에요 이게
예술가 지망생 분들중에도 굉장히 많고
꼭 그런 사람이 쓴 책같애
그러니까 저는 이번에 다시 읽으면서
혜진님처럼
전 진짜 영영 이해를 못하다가
20대때 읽을때는
이번에 처음으로 좀 공감을 했어요
그러니까 이렇게까지 극단으로
가지 않아도
누구나 사회적인 가면을 쓰잖아요
근데 저도
웃음사냥꾼으로 살아왔고
잘 아시겠지만
웃음사냥꾼
익살,재미 이런거 굉장히 저도 추구하고
재미있는 사람이 되고 싶고
항상 웃기고 싶어 하거든요 남들을
아 그때 고백하셨죠 근데
웃기는 것이 내 삶의 전부라고
사실은 코미디언의 꿈이라고
맞아
사실은 근데 그러면서도
남들이 웃으면
너무 보람을 느끼면서도
내가 근데 왜 맨날 나가서
이렇게 익살을 떨고 있을까
이게 의문이 드는 때도 있거든요
왜냐면은 저는 사실은
제가 스스로를 생각했을때는
그렇게 유쾌하고 밝은 사람이 아니에요
그래서 제가 많이 듣는 말이
어디가서 귀 안죽는다
씩씩하다
당차다 이런 말을 듣는데
난 진짜 왜 내 모습을 보여주지 못하는가
난 왜 맨날 웃긴 얘기
시답지 않은 얘기만 해서
남들이 웃는 얼굴을 보고
안심하고 나도 웃고
이렇게 하는 것만 하다가 집에 갈까
그런게 좀 현타가 올 때가 있어요
그런 면에서 좀 공감이 됐어요
이번에 읽으면서
전 사실 진짜 익살 많이 떨거든요
전 저 혼자 집에 있을 때도
혼자한테 춤을 춰줄 때도 있어요
그래서 맨날 저한테 잘 자라고 해요
근데 그 말이 너무 웃겨서
맨날 푸하하 이렇게 웃거든요
하하하하하하하하하
겁지 않고 슬퍼요
아니 그 말을 하는게 너무 웃기잖아요
잘자 이렇게 하는게
하하하하하하하
이소라 이소라 플레이 해가지고
얘기하고 보니까
좀 싸이코 같은데
저는 좀 공감이 됐어요
왜냐면 자기애랑 자기혐오는
진짜 종이 한 장체라 저는 생각하거든요
거의 비슷한
극단의 자기애로 가면 자기혐오가 되요
왜냐면 난 나를 너무너무 사랑하는데
왜 그렇게 못해줘
난 쓰레기야
나는 진짜 죽어야돼 죽자
하면서도 아니야
나 사실 날 너무 사랑해 하는게
계속 반복되는데
사실 다 그렇게 살잖아요 솔직히 인정하고 싶지 않지만
반복하지 않나요
딱 같은 의미로
세상을 혐오하는 이 요조가
진짜 세상을 사랑하는거에요
사실은 인간을 너무 사랑하는거에요
사실은 주변 사람들이 너무 사랑하는거에요
여기에 막 어떤 시가 나오는데
거기에 막 이런 문장이 있거든요
거칠고 큰 기쁨을 피하기만 한다면
자연이 큰 슬픔 또한 찾아오지 않는다
근데 저는 이게 요조가
나는 거칠고 큰 기쁨을
기대하지 않겠어 라는 말로 느꼈어요
그러니까 이제 기대하지 않는거에요
근데 그 나 기대하지 않겠어
라고 말하는 사람의 마음은
항상 가장 기대를 하고 있거든요
이 세상
이 사람들에 대한 기대가 너무 크고
이 사람이 온전히 나에게
진심을 주길 바라는 마음이 너무 크니까
그 어떤 사람의 이중적인 마음이
이런 것도 보기가 너무 두려워하고
그런 것들도
사실은 정말로 이 사람의
마음을 너무 얻고 싶어서
이 사람의 신뢰를 너무 얻고 싶어서 하는
기대감 때문이 아닐까 라는 생각이 들더라구요
근데 어느정도 공감하시잖아
공감은 하는데
남한테 피해주면 안되지
그거에 뭐 당연한 소리를 도덕 교과서 같은 소리를 하고 있어요
아니 죽을거면 혼자 죽어야지
왜 자꾸 남을 꼬십니까
맞잖아요
그럼 같이 죽던가
빨리 죽던가
시작할 때는 저는 막연하게
우리는 되게 포멀한 삶을 사는 직장인이고
여기는 자유분방한 아티스트라고
스테레타입을 생각하면서
토론 시작을 했는데
막상 뚜껑을 열어보니까
우리는 되게
아무나 다 이해하고
다 이해돼
소설 속에서 다 이해돼
주변인들이 너무 불쌍해서 그래
너무 불쌍해
정말 그 딱 틀이 있으신 것 같아요
완전 반대인 것 같아요
그러니까 꼰대 같다고 말씀하신 거잖아요
아니요 약간 달라요
뭔가 어떻게 생각하면
말 그대로 그냥 틀?
그게 그거잖아요
사실 다자이 535
인간실격이
제가 처음에 입사할 때
10년 전만 해도
누구나 아는 작품이긴 하지만 그렇게 초 베스트셀러는 아니었어요
근데 그 이후로
2010년대 후반부터
갑자기 이제 정말
1위 2위 세계문학 전집
4,500권 중에서
다투는 작품이 된 건데
제 그 파트너도
처음에 인간실격을 읽게 된 이유가
자기가
최종 면접까지 간 적이 있었어요
저희가 대학생 때 커플이었는데
근데 정말 될 줄 알았다가 떨어진 거예요
망친 거죠
그리고 저는 학교로 다시 돌아와서
도서관에 갔는데
인간실격이라는 책이 꽂혀있는데
그냥 내 얘기가 돼서 집었대요
그리고 저는 처음부터 끝까지 읽었다라고 얘기를 하는데
뭔가 내가 너무
초라해 보이는 날
다자이 오사모를 읽으면
어 근데 얘보다 내가 낫지 않나
라는 생각으로
책을 적으면서
위안을 받는 게 있어요
우는 아이를 한 번 더 때려주는 느낌
가장 나약한 모습을 보여주기 때문에
오히려 위로를 받는 면이 있어서
그 다자이 오사모의
통곡이 약간
솔직하고
위안을 주는 게 있는 것 같아요
근데 인간실격 제목은
진짜 잘 지은 것 같은 느낌이 있어요
정말 팍팍 꽂히잖아요
너무 잘 만들었어요
제가 여기서 정말 마음에 드는 거는
그때 당시에 어떤
일본의
느낌? 약간 아기자기한
마을의 느낌들이 좀 나는 거가
좀 좋고
배경을
머릿속에서 지브리스타일로
지브리스타일로 이렇게
요조가 사는 마을 말이야
요조가 사는 마을
마을 느낌이 좋았다
좋았다
여기서 토토로 나오고
상상력이 좋아
사실은 지브리를 엄청 좋아하는 거 아니에요?
매화 지브리 얘기를 하시네요
어떻게 알았지?
그거 싫어하는 사람이 있어요?
자 두 분 오늘
독서클럽에 이렇게 또
나와주신 소감은
좀 들어볼 수 있을까요?
혜진님 오늘 어떠셨나요?
이런 거 생전 처음 해보시죠
북클럽 많이 해보셨지 않았어요?
트레바리
이거 북클럽이에요
그러니까 어땠어요 혜진님
현실적인 북클럽은 처음 하시는 거죠
사실 되게
저는 재밌었어요
제가 재밌게 하지 못한 거 같아서
좀 약간 걱정이 되지만
저는 되게 재밌었던 게
어쨌든 제가 그냥 막연하게
영상 속으로 보던 두 분의 모습이랑
책을 매개로 얘기해본 모습이
다른 정도가 아니라
정반대의 모습들이 많이 나와서
그게 되게 재밌었는데
사실 이 정도 밀도의 대화를
하려면 그냥 이렇게
만나서는
한 1년 2년 정도
지나야 들어갈 수 있는
그 우회로를 굉장히 많이 거쳐야
들어갈 수 있는
그 깊이로 바로 다이빙하게 해주는 게
책의 매력인 것 같고
오늘 처음 만난 사람이랑
뭔가
더 진전된 대화를 하는
방법이
제 인생 경험에서 세 가지 정도가 있는 것 같아요
하나는 술
하나는 여행
그리고 하나는 책인데
책이 그 중에서 가장 싸잖아요
가장 싸고
저는 손쉽다고 생각하거든요
그래서
책을 매개로
다이빙해서 이야기 들어볼 수 있는
시간이 된 것 같아서
저는 개인적으로 되게 뿌듯하고
즐거웠습니다
저는 여기 항상
혼자 오다가
제가
늘 진짜 일상을 같이 하는
한 여자가 여기에 와서
이걸 같이 공유했다고
하는 거 자체가 너무 재밌었고요
반대로 두 분이
책을 읽고 하는 대화가
진짜 흥미로웠어요
어떤 건 제 예상과
같이 흘러갔지만
어떤 건 정말 우와 깜짝 놀랐다
어떻게 저 사람 입에서 저 말이 나오지
하는 신선한
놀라움이 있는데
그게 이게 이렇게 어둠의 독서클럽이 아니라
그냥 어떤 독서클럽을 해도
사실 일어나는 일이거든요
항상 의외의 말을 의외의 사람이 해요
그때 저는 너무 기쁨을 느끼고
너무 재밌었고
저는 책을 너무 좋아하니까
좋아하는 걸로 가득찬
정말 훈훈한 시간이었습니다
허키님 오늘 어떠셨어요?
저는 뭐 이렇게 북클럽 트레바리
뭐 이런 거 태어나서 처음 해보고요
근데 너무 아까 말씀하신 거랑
완전히 공감해요
이걸 통해서 이렇게 한 사람에 대해서
많이 알아가고
의견 얘기할 수 있는 일이
뭐 살면서 몇 번이나 있겠어요
없을 것 같아요 많이
책을 읽어야 된다는 사실이
좀 힘들지만
그만큼의 가치가 충분히 있는 그런 시간이었다
간지님은 어떻게?
저요? 저는 뭐
늘 하던 거니까
책 좋아하는 여자 만난 적 있죠?
뭘요?
아니 그런 감이 왔어요
아까 대화 도중에
책을 좋아하는 여자를 사귄 적 있죠?
부지기수죠
아 그래도 좌충우돌
우리가
잘 흘러왔다
정말 또 오늘 너무 좋으신
게스트분을 모시고
다음에 또 하죠 저희
또 해요
그러면은 20페이지 이하로 하십시오
하하하하하하
아니 시로 하자
시로 하자
자 비주류 초대석 오늘은
민음사 박혜진 편집자님과 함께
책 이야기를 떠들어 봤고요
언제일지는 모르겠지만
다음 시간에 다른 주제에
돌아오겠습니다
다같이 안녕 할까요?
안녕
수고하셨습니다